you overcome to this video Danny man 10
Danny man 10 okay hmm let's see okay I
mean I tend to play them tomorrow off so
he success kind of fitting into all that
okay is he playing Bishop b5 that's not
mmm no one to totally non theoretical
option with d3 okay don't mind to take
the center hmm yeah that's a funny way
to play HD 3d form I wonder this is some
kind of reverse something it's a bit
like every worst french exchange with c4
something like that hmm h3
yeah okay I should play something so
it's kind of kind of useless useless
useless Lee spend time could have played
any move basically quickly it's kind of
still amazed at what is going D 3 then d
4 + h 3 but ok just sitting there being
astonished by that doesn't help it just
takes too much time ok just playing
playing normal moves basically he might
be able to take on f6 on c5 anand d 5
but i always have something else take
that won't be too ok let's maybe gain
some space it's not not looking bad i
think for black got quite an active
looking position what he can try us no
we won't I was thinking he could try to
put something on e5 but this is no
impossible what he might try to do is
maybe he can take on c4 play d5
something like that it looks kind of
unlikely to work ok so i'm preparing b5
yeah this is walking into some kind of
pin or oh it goes Bishop of them rookie
three hmm ok I'm can do that I can't
that's gained some space maybe be sure
before wasn't that great with hindsight
ok let's gain that space here it's not
too bad and now hmm justjust do that if
he takes there and goes d5 I can take g5
because a one is hanging or maybe root
dat you know ok doesn't care about any
about about whatever I'm doing ok so i
can take their take a one okay yes you
can stick c6 at the end and and i have
worked yet but in that case it probably
has Bishop c4 wow it's also not bad
actually
okay Bishop d525 group a one Quincy six
not sure about that so let's do this
should be five rock 25 25 Queen a one
check i'm picking out back a form as
well now covers the c6 night ok so let's
take that a 95 strong 95 Wow
fania sometimes those totally
coincidental tactics they decide games
we had tons of good options but i just
stumbled into that silly thing yeah it's
especially funny because he he didn't
plan any of that it just it just
happened it just happened okay what is
the point 9700 k I mean I can I cannot
move those pawns really and maybe still
check
his chick here doesn't really help me
night jeez six-time morning I still have
that pawn so
I can probably even play Queen e5 or
move like that Colleen e5 is pretty
strong yes maybe I should have gone to
some other square it's probably lost
anyway but okay black design what a
weird game yeah like it's just are just
much better here and somehow as I
stumbled into that we are tactic okay
the engine suggests not to take on see
three but the out human there's some
logic behind that but anyway I don't I
don't believe this one bit here Rock t8
so what is what exactly happened to him
ok this is what I originally wanted to
do but ok this is hanging so that's not
working but I thought that this I mean
it looks like I'm winning a pond this is
this is this is the move yeah 35 yeah
okay i can i can still on no Queen have
six year but that's not really what what
I wanted to do of course it's it's okay
i mean it's it's a neat it's an equal
position yeah I had planned Queen takes
a four and then he had the silly 95 move
to justice very stupid play by black gym
jim was there some way to punish the
speed opening I mean probably not yeah
not nothing particularly great okay I
mean this the way it progressed was ok I
mean this is a good position here the
engine wants to go knight to e7 ik black
has an advantage in space and two
bishops and there was no particular
reason for me to to take on c3 I just
wanted to have the space and I thought
okay you cannot take on c4 know when
term he went for that very quickly
yeah it would have been indeed much
better to just keep them and keep the
tension here yeah that's rather
comfortable i also have night f5
sometimes idea 596 some some ideas like
that that's quite nice actually yeah but
it was stupid i should have firm i
really should have reconsidered when I
when I did this yet that took that very
quickly and i only saw 95 right after
right after I took it I was several some
stupid mistake I should take a minute II
another minute air but a moment and and
see that 95 is happening okay well
thanks for watching